donald trump sagt mit mir würde es
putins krieg heute nicht geben jetzt
werden wir hingegen in einem atomkrieg
ende nein große klappe interview war das
der ex-us-präsident beim britischen star
talker piers morgan unzensiert so heißt
es neue show und der gast donald trump
auge in auge der talker und tanja und
spricht über putin über den krieg wirft
dem kompletten westen vor sich viel zu
klein zu machen selbst viel zu wenig
knallharte drohungen nach moskau zu
schicken und jump sagt dann diesen satz
putin hätte es nie getan er hätte es
nicht gemacht er hätte es also mit mir
mit donald trump als präsident der
vereinigten staaten nicht getan diesen
angriffskrieg in der ukraine er bei
aller großen klappe ist da was dran sind
wir alle viel zu ängstlich vor putin
bräuchte der westen mehr große klappe
mit tram kein putin krieg darüber
sprechen wir jetzt mit unserem
korrespondenten in der ukraine mit
unserem bild reporter paul ronzheimer
schönen guten morgen paul also ein große
klappe interview das haben wir gerade
gesehen beim britischen torka piers
morgan jump der sagt mit mir würde es
putins angriffskrieg heute nicht geben
und er sagt ja wir werden in einem
atomkrieg kenntnis irgendwas dran
ich glaube nicht dass wir in einem
atomkrieg enden werden kann aber dennoch
ist natürlich etwas dran wenn donald
trumps sagt dass wir zu ängstlich sind
was wladimir putin angeht und da müssen
wir vor allem nach deutschland schauen
wir haben olaf scholz erlebt in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten und viele
glauben dass putin ihn in einem
persönlichen gespräch sogar angst
gemacht haben könnte vielleicht dort
sogar mit einem atomschlag zumindest
taktischen atomschlag in der ukraine
gedroht haben könnte also deswegen
glaube ich dass an dem punkt dass wir zu
ängstlich waren was wladimir putin
angeht durchaus etwas dran ist auch vor
dem krieg muss man das ja ganz klar
sagen da haben alle gesagt auf gar
keinen fall diesen man provozieren denn
ansonsten könnte es zu diesem krieg
kommen und das wollen wir alle nicht und
deswegen ist möglicherweise auch
wladimir putin überhaupt erst bereit
gewesen diesen krieg zu gehen weil er
dachte dass der westen eben nicht geeint
reagieren würde wie es heute wie es
jetzt ich glaube dass sich der westen
insgesamt wenn wir uns die usa anschauen
wenn wir uns großbritannien anschauen
wollen wir uns vor allem osteuropäische
staaten anschauen durchaus heftig gegen
wladimir putin stellt das heißt man
braucht auch jetzt noch eine große
klappe es ist nicht zu spät für diese
große klappe pauli ist das richtige
vorgehen jetzt in dieser situation in
den nächsten tagen
ich glaube große klappe bedeutet ja
gleichzeitig auch immer aber nichts
dahinter deswegen glaube ich dass die
große klappe bei wladimir putin nicht
hilft er ist geheimdienstler er kann
lesen ob am ende da etwas hinter steht
es geht darum entschieden zu reagieren
in jedem sinne sowohl wirtschaftlich als
auch militärisch und wenn wir uns diese
beiden komponenten anschauen dann muss
man sagen insbesondere bei den
sanktionen haben wir wladimir putin
bislang nicht überrascht das war alles
eingepreist dass aber eventuell wir über
öl und gas sprechen könnten dass man
nicht eingepreist wobei er jetzt selbst
schritte gerade geht das zweite sind
militärische fragen da kann man sagen
dass die usa besonders entschieden eben
hier geholfen hat in den vergangenen
monaten und den vergangenen wochen vor
allem und wenn wir
uns donald trump anschauen der waren
seiner russland politik immer hin- und
hergerissen manchmal hat er sich
bewundernd geäußert für wladimir putin
sie dann wieder scharf aber das ja nie
genau genie aber dass er jetzt der klare
hardliner gewesen wäre das ist falsch
wir holen paul und sein us
korrespondenten dazu mit in unser
gespräch herbert bauernebel live aus new
york zugeschaltet herbert diese sätze
die rühren heute die weltnummer auf die
rühren sicherlich auch die usa oder vor
allen dingen die usa noch einmal auf
dieses interview von ex-us-präsident
donald trump beim britischen torka piers
morgan jump der sarg mit mir wird das
diesen krieg heute putins angriffskrieg
nicht geben so werden wir in einem
atomkrieg enden heißt dass beiden viel
zu klein laut ist dass auch die usa viel
zu klein laut sind
ja es ist keine überraschung die worte
von ex-präsident damals natürlich ist
lässt sich schwer nachvollziehen was
wirklich passiert wäre wenn donald trump
die wiederwahl gewonnen hätte er
jedenfalls ist felsenfest davon
überzeugt dass er ab lade mir putin
ausreichend gewarnt hätte solche
schritte zu tun donald trump ist der
ansicht dass und mit ihm als präsidenten
es zu all dem nicht gekommen wäre denn
er so wie er behauptet jedenfalls cap
premier putin unmissverständlich gedroht
dass er das ist schwere vernichtende
furchtbare konsequenzen geben würde für
russland und laut kampeter bleibt mir
protein das geglaubt natürlich all das
lässt sich nicht nachvollziehen und
nicht beweisen denn donald trump hat
überall verloren wurde abgewählt und joe
biden der demokrat ist demnach wie folgt
ins weiße haus aber natürlich diese
ansätze dieses interview sorgt auch in
den usa für große aufregung natürlich
von donald trump sind wir das ja gewohnt
dieses selbstbewusste auftreten das auch
ganz oft ein paar größenwahnsinnige züge
hatte aber wie kommen diese worte bei
den amerikanern an wie ist dort die
stimmung denkt man dort wir bräuchten
mehr klare kante wir bräuchten mehr
selbstbewusstsein auch vielleicht so ein
bisschen trump selbstbewusstsein
es ist höchst wahrscheinlich dass die
mehrheit der amerikaner jetzt nicht
jedes wort von dort haben für bare münze
nimmt und nicht daran glaubt dass mit
ihm als präsidenten der krieg zu
verhindern gewesen wäre aber klar ist
gleichzeitig das auch die politik von
joe biden nicht besonders gut ankommt
bei den amerikanern international hat
joe biden zustimmung gefunden im sinne
dass er den westen geeint hat gegen
russland dass er russland isoliert oder
auch die waffenlieferungen zumindest
zeit ist der amerikaner funktionieren ja
ganz gut aber insgesamt
so beiden doch immer wieder ein bild das
schwäche das liegt auch oft an seinen
zerbrechlichen auftritten seinen
wortmeldungen die nicht ganz klar sind
klar ist für den mehrheit der amerikaner
dass sie sich einen resoluten führer
wünschen würden in dieser krise und joe
biden diese diese herausforderungen
nicht gewachsen ist derzeit dank an
unseren us korrespondenten herbert
bauernebel live aus new york zu diesem
große klappe interview von donald trump
beim britischen torka piers morgan wir
schauen noch einmal auf seine sätze auf
die von donald trump also der da sagt
wir werden in einem atomkrieg enden der
selbst in diesem interview immer wieder
drohungen richtung moskau schickte und
man die haben doch selber viel mehr
atomwaffen sagte er in diesem interview
wir müssten damit hohen und dann sagt er
das ist schon ein weltkrieg putin hätte
es nie getan er hätte es nicht gemacht
er hätte es also mit mir mit mir als
us-präsident nie getan